بغدادي متابعه مؤتمر الصحفي لوزير
الخارجيه العراقي فؤاد حسين وامين عام
الامم المتحده
والخدمات
ومحاربه الفقر ومكافحه الفساد
والاصلاحات الاقتصاديه
وننتظر هنا
دعم من الامم المتحده عبر الوكالات
والبرامج والانشطه بهذا الصدد
نحن ماضون في ارساء معادله الاستقرار
حكومتنا خلقت حاله من الاستقرار السياسي
والامني
واليوم العراق هو مفتاح للحل في المنطقه
وليس جزء من مشكله امنيه وسياسيه
نعمل على جنب الفرقاء والاراء المتناقضه
في العراق الذي نرى انه يلعب دور رياضي
بين الاشقاء والاصدقاء
لخلق هذا النظام الاقليمي المستقر والذي
ينعكس قطعا على الاستقرار في عموم المنطقه
والعالم
نعمل على ايجاد شراكات اقتصاديه بحكم ما
يتمتع به العراق من ثروات طبيعيه وبشريه
وموقع جغرافي
نعمل على
الاعداد
لمؤتمر بغداد ثلاثه
وفق رؤيه الحكومه الجديده
والتي تختلف جذريا
كون
نرى
الجميع يجب ان يلتقي في بغداد
وفق رؤيه الاقتصاد والشراكه والتعاون وهذا
ما نعمل عليه من اجل اكمال مشاريع الترابط
البنيوي والخدمات
والاستثمارات المتبادله والشراكات
الاقتصاديه
هذا الهدف الذي نعمل عليه وهذه الرؤيه
نابعه من التغيير في طبيعه التحديات التي
نواجهها
العراق
سياده الامين العام يواجه تحديات على
مستوى المناخ
وارتفاع نسبه التصحر
وشحت الامطار والذي اثر بشكل كبير على
الحياه في البلد فضلا عن التاثيرات
المناخيه الاخرى
وتزامن هذا الامر مع سياسات مائيه للدول
المتشاطئه سواء بتقليل الاطلاقات المائيه
او تغيير مجاري تلك الانهر وهذا يشكل تحدي
للحياه عموما هناك مواقع تمثل
مراكز مهمه في لائحه التراث العالمي اليوم
مهدده
بسبب شحه المياه وهذه التغييرات المناخيه
ننتظر من الامم المتحده دعم العراق في
جهوده بهذا الشان
ايضا اود ان اسجل الشكر والتقدير لفريق
التحقيق التابع للامم المتحده
لتحقيق المسائله عن جرائم المرتكبه من قبل
داعش
نتعاون معه على مدى سنوات
وسوف نستمر بهذا التعاون لجمع الادله التي
تدين مجرمين داعش
لتسليم الادله الى جميع المحاكم الوطنيه
العراقيه والمحاسبه هؤلاء المجرمين واحقاق
العداله لعوائل الضحايا
العراق قطع شوط مهم في نجلاء وايواء
واغاثه النازحين وتقديم الخدمات لهم
وعودتهم الامنه والطوعيه الى مناطق سكناهم
ننتظر من باقي الدول ممارسه هذا الدور
لمنع هذه المواقع من ان تكون محطه
لممارسات تساهم في اعاده الارهاب وتهديد
الامن والاستقرار في المنطقه
شكرا
سياده رئيس الوزراء شكرا لكم على هذا
الترحيب الحار
يسعدني ان اعود ان اعود يسعدني ان اعود
الى العراق
في الماضي زرت بلادكم اكثر من مره ولكن
الان ارى عرقا
وانتهينا من اجتماع مثمر انا هنا في زياره
للتضامن
للتاكيد على التزام الامم المتحده بدعم
العراق في ترسيخ مؤسسته الديمقراطيه
لتعزيز السلام
والتنميه وحقوق الانسان لجميع العراقيين
ندرك ان تحدي يواجهها العراق لم تحدث بين
ليله وضحاها هي نتيجه عقود من الحروب
والطائفيه وتدخلات الخارجيه
ولا يمكن ان نتوقع لح هذه المشكلات في
ليله وضحاها ولكن هناك هناك امل تحقيق هذا
التقدم ونحن
ونحن نامل ونتاكد من حدوث هذا ويشجعني
تشكيل الحكومه الجديده
وبرنامجها الاصلاح التطلعي
واحيي رئيس الوزراء على التزامه على
معالجه التحديات التي تواجهها البلاد بما
في ذلك محاربه الفساد تحسين الخدمات
العامه
وتنويع الاقتصاد لتقليل البطاله وخلق فرص
خاصه للشباب
هذه التغييرات تتطلب اصلاحا ممنهجا
ومؤسسات قويه ومساءله اقوى
وحوكمه افضل على جميع المستويات والامم
المتحده تبدي استعدادها لدعم جميع هذه
الجهود المهمه
لقد ناقشنا اهميه البناء على الخطوات
الايجابيه القائمه بين بغداد واربيل
والتحرك نحو حوار مؤسسي واتفاق مستدام
السيد رئيس الوزراء اعرف ان مساله الامن
المائي هي قضيه انت تهتم بها تهتمون بها
بشكل خاص ان في هذا منذ عشر الاف عام بدات
النهضه الزراعيه في الهلال الخاصي
الان في بلاد ما بين النهرين ولكن الدجله
والحراث الان يا جفان تدفق المياه قل بشكل
كبير
ويفطر قلبي ان ارى ان المزارعين يتركون
الاراضي التي كانوا يزرعون فيها لالاف
السنين قله المياه في العراق يزيد عليها
ايضا قله المياه القادمه من الخارج
والمزيد من التغيرات المناخيه انه تهديد
يتطلب
انتباها عالميا نحن نعقد
مؤتمر المياه في نيويورك هذا الشهر
ونتطلع لمشاركه العراق في هذا المؤتمر
ان العراق من بين الدول الاكثر تاثرا
بتغير المناخ هذا لا يعني فقط الهشاشه
البيئيه والحراره العاليه والتصحر بل ايضا
يؤدي الى النزوح ويهدد الامن الغذائي
ويهدد سبل العيش
ويقلل يقود من حقوق الانسان خاصه للفئات
الاكثر ضعفا
الى جانب
التحديات الحكومه واتحدث الامنيه قد يضع
ذلك يشكل تهديد للاستقرار وهذا حقيقي في
العراق وفي اي منطقه في المنطقه
وهذا ليس تهديدا بل انه الخطر القائم
حاليا